so we already learnt about
why and how ngs is going to help us
characterize different whole genome
sequences of these infectious diseases
and why in the context of why it is
going to be very important in ah perform
an analysis like negative sequencing and
sequencing methodology to uh identify or
to sequence the whole genome of
pathogens so let's let's go through some
of the important concepts or some of the
important outlines of how negative
sequencing data is generated and what
are the different file forms that are
associated with nextion sequencing data
and how we can
use the talbot by info platform to run a
pipeline for this sequencing
data analysis
so yeah
so this is very important because it it
is related to our ability to compare the
dna code of any given
system
in this case like a virus or or even a
bacteria to a reference
sequence of the same system right um if
you if you want to identify a new strain
in the
that is circulating around in during
this pandemic then we sequence this um
sequencer data from the samples uh that
have a different behavioral
characteristics of the different
virulence and then compare it with the
reference genome that is
characterized in the database so let's
uh this is these these analyses and
these different uh these um these
different technologies are made possible
through the advances that takes millions
and millions of cheaply generated short
read sequences and align them to a
reference
that will help us extract meaningful
insights uh in the biological system
that we are considering so this
sequencing technology actually helps us
to explore genetic variations like
like never before
like we can use different types of the
sequencing to address the particular
specific need that we want to
address like in the case of a targeted
sequencing panel we will have high
coverage but we are going to target only
40 to 400 genes in the in terms of um
human genome or if you want to target
specific genes in terms of viral genome
we don't have to do that because viral
sequences are genomes are tend to be
very short in length and people go for
whole genome sequencing of pathogens
that is like virus etc but in terms of a
human genome then we can use uh targeted
sequencing or whole exome sequencing or
whole genome sequencing to
tailor the kind of sequencing
experiment that we want to perform on
the samples that we have so these three
different sequencing efforts they have
their own advantages and disadvantages
so some of the advantages that would
categorize or differentiate them is the
design questions are there is the um
biological implications that they can be
used to perform like whole genome
sequencing can be helped ah
even though in spite of low coverage uh
can be performed on a large number of
samples to identify
specifically um
those variants which are very rare and
their association with the disease state
or association with the phenotypical
history that the
samples are
actually
representing or depicting whole exome
sequencing will give you a trans
transcriptomic snapshot of the uh of the
system at the particular time so that is
going to give you the expression
profiles or
give you the expression quantification
of all the
coding
coding genes
at that particular snapshot and targeted
sequencing panel will help you
specifically target little portions of
the genome so that we can
perform or we can understand their
variation with respect to the reference
sequence at a very high coverage so that
very rare mutations and very rare
variants can be analyzed and identified
and then addressed
addressed with with lot of confidence
so ah so how this is done so this is
done by um
this is done by uh
by first um collecting or first sharing
the genomic dna into uh into multiple
small
fragments of 200 to 300 base pairs and
then we attach the adapters to these
to these fragments and then these
adapters are then
attached adapters are then applied to
the flow cell where they are
then
amplified using a bridge pcr technique
and then
these amplified
sheared fragments are then sequenced by
the sequencer machine uh in um
and these sequenced
fragments are called as sequence calls
uh depending upon their
specific nucleotide in a t g or
c so
so the g the ngs sequencing machine or
sequencing technology basically converts
or basically uh takes the
biological sample and converts them into
a digital sequencing data that it uh
gives us an output in the form of fast q
files so these outputs that we have uh
from the ngs sequencing uh
machines and j sequencing technology or
high throughput sequencing technology
are given us in ah fast queue format so
first q format is
yes a fast queue format
and we we also there is also another
format that is
related to first q and is very
very important in the
analysis pipeline of this ngo sequencing
sequencing data uh that is faster format
and gta format let's go through first
queue format first and then let's come
back to the first day format uh
so the first queue format the first key
file reads like this so the fascia files
has a
starting header which contains the
important information such as the read
name their length and different sample
characteristics and all the different
characteristics that one can associate
with this particular read and the next
line um
describes the next line actually depicts
the actual calls of the nucleotide
themselves so this is these are the
actual actual reads actual
sequences that are sequenced by the ngs
sequencers and then we have a separator
that is usually that usually separates
these
base calls from the quality scores that
is associated with each one of these
base calls and that separator is a is a
plus sign and sometimes this this
separated line is also populated with
the same information that one finds with
the header so and then after the
separator we get the
quality scores that is associated with
each and every one of these base calls
in ascii format so these each and every
one of these characters represent or
they actually tell us how confident we
are or how confident the uh sequencing
um technology is about uh the placement
is about the call of this particular um
a particular base at that point at that
specific position this is used right
throughout our downstream analysis where
first this is used to filter uh those
reads which are of low quality and then
even until the end where we can
associate our
variant
through the
variant identified variance
with the
quality score that
that it is attached to or that it is
called with so let's go back to the
fasta file format this is another file
format which is used usually used in the
uh ngs sequencing pipeline where when
when we have to map the first queue
files or the reads and the fascia files
format to the reference genome so first
a file format is usually reserved for
the reference genome where this file
format is a very simple text based file
format where the first line star usually
starts with the greater than symbol and
then what follows is the header for this
first q file fasta file
for the whole genome sequence of this
file so
this header will have important
information like accession id the name
of the species and
in addition to that they can also have
the strain names or isolate names or or
the type of
technology used to sequence this data
and etc etc and and after that what
follows is the actual whole genome
sequence of this
whole genome sequence of this particular
species for example in this uh it's a
spot of terra and in this case it's an
ibis virus so this is the this is the
genome sequence right from the first
nucleotide to the last nucleotide uh
given in a you know one single line or
one single uh
entry so this doesn't actually describe
uh
in terms of eukaryotic genome which
portions of this
genome sequence are coding sequences or
which portions of this genome sequence
are non-coding sequences or which
which portions are x1 x1 or intron in
terms of within gene so that information
is actually loaded or that information
is actually supplied with a gtf file so
the or gff file
which tells us at what position can we
find the uh coding region at what
position can we find the
exons and what position can we find the
non-coding regions of this in this fasta
file for the reference sequence so these
three are absolutely essential for
performing a uh
performing a ngs
pipeline analysis of
sequence to data
and what happens is the fastq files
which represent the reads that are
that are sequenced they are mapped on to
the reference genome which in the faster
files are here you can see the reference
genome and then these are the reads that
are mapped onto this particular position
specific position based on the sequence
alignment or based on the sequence
identity on this one so here
uh
it's yeah this is a detailed view of how
this is performed and how this can be
visualized so uh
in this in this representation here this
this gray bar
represents the genome sequence uh and
this
big gray bar represents the gene and
these ones are non-coding areas
non-coding regions and these blue bars
and red bars represents the the red bars
and blue bars represents the
forward stand and reverse strand
respectively and they can be mapped like
this onto the reference genome and then
identify and then their specific
and the variation that is present in
these first q files with respect to
reference genome can be identified and
then they can be characterized so to
visualize the whole mapping and the
whole
and the processes of this
mapping and output they can be
visualized using
some visualizing tool like a jbrowser or
igd and these are the use standard
visualizing tools that one uses to
visualize this
mapping algorithm
so here
so here we have the reference sequence
that is mentioned in this one and then
what follows is the consensus or what
follows is the coverage of this uh
of this map
reads so we have we do not have a
uniform coverage because of the
technology it is not uniformly uh red or
it's not uniformly sequenced at all the
levels so
these chunks of small fast q files these
some chunks of small reads they get
mapped to the genome and based on their
based on their
coverage like here we have really high
coverage where we have many very many
reads that are aligned at this position
so we see that the coverage is really
high but here the coverage is very very
low or very shallow because we do not
have a lot of reads at this particular
position so these um this can be
visualized and and
in addition to visualizing the mapping
of these uh regions of the genome we can
also
identify specific mutation at this part
positions which can also be uh
visualized
in this one so let me quickly go to uh
target bioinfo platform and
show you how to run a simple
visualization pipeline for uh
for a viral genome so let's take it
forward there and
and then come back again to here
screen
can you see my screen
i think you can see my screen
let's yeah let's go to server.tbioinfo
and then here if you uh go to genomics
analysis and then and then under
mutation variant and parallel analysis
of mutation variant data you drop down
so we have prepared some
demo pipelines and demo um
yeah demo pipelines which will give you
the feeling of running these analysis or
running this pipeline building up this
pipeline for this sequence analysis and
then
you can access the output files and you
can
perform the similar analysis that we are
performing in the
using
output file you can visualize you can
perform
a downstream analysis with the output
file and you can learn what these files
can be what these uh
pipelines can be built for and how the
output can be
leverage to perform multiple
analysis so let's
yeah let's uh build this start
here usually the input files are
uploaded because it is a demo pipeline
and we uh then after starting we map the
reads onto the uh genome using bow tie
two algorithm
and we go there and then after this we
uh complete this pipeline with
visualization
tool and we end it in the pipeline and
after you end the pipeline you get
access to download all the pipeline
results where we have uh the mapping
statistics of these reads mapped onto
the genome and we have the
sequence alignment map or
sam file which is the alignment file uh
mapped file in in
in a in a
some format this is also this can also
be given in a binary alignment map file
in binary format and we have the input
first q files that we have provided for
this mapping or provided for this
analysis and this is the um
yeah i think this is the reference
genome and then let's if under